hey welcome to wack yo neighbor we
played all the other wack yo games do
you remember just minding my own
business and Edgar comes around and we
teleport so the goal of this game is to
oh my god calm down did you just poke my
nips do it again please
there ya go there ya go you click on
things should happen oh my god
don't point at my crotch alright the
garbage it's a trap we straight up
murdered our neighbor and try to cover
it up what a game I'm enjoying this yeah
whatever those are call shoot me oh my
god do do you do not have to do that
there's 27 different ones what is this
thing this game is [ __ ] up what about
the barbecue no do you want a hot dog
dip your face in there
the tree
take this oh man this is just ridiculous
violence doesn't solve anything except
debt and deficits a lot of things
actually don't put me on that
oh my god [ __ ] that he has a nice ass I
gotta give it to him at least that
gasoline shake that ass blow me girl
I mean legitimately he just complained
about my dog taking a [ __ ] on his lawn I
don't understand why I have to kill him
for that but catch if you can dodge
friends you can dodge a ball I ordered
some oh my god [ __ ] sake
why do you keep doing this what is your
prob I god no
what are we gonna do now oh [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] up
oh my god Oh
hands back that get a boy okay let's say
keep I'll have your legs for this sir
let's make some leg soup I'm a really
good chef oh no shame on you
disgusting upsetting Karthik no no don't
do it it's not worth that he's [ __ ] up
okay
five minutes later okay takes five
minutes to set that [ __ ] up
no no oh all right all right all right
we tried a lot of them I feel like I
don't believe Garden shovel I guess that
can make you leave you only done
that will do the trick a little flower
that's great
stick it up as s oh nice yes a great ass
so I understand where that's coming from
I've seen this in a Japanese supporter
what I mean all right next one the sink
now that's the grill damn it Shane huh
found you mistltein now where are we
five minutes later 24 hours later Oh
4:15 no while he's skinny man forty
bucks a one-year I can click on the dog
directly another you know
no God no shotgun
it's about that I just [ __ ] up
she's [ __ ] up I don't understand there
must be some tiny little [ __ ] hiding
Jane Jane why do you take a chance
Hey I guess you could say he had split
personalities no no no nail guns less
nails equals oh my god oh dude Brad oh
there's a laser
there's a [ __ ] laser are you [ __ ]
kidding me
don't no no no boy bad boy but no no no
spatula
oh my god Jesus okay one more where is
it I don't understand there we go
sponsor eagle sponsor Eagles he became
nothing great
and there you that concludes we're whack
your neighbor such a wacky game if you
enjoyed this video leave a like
subscribe goodnight and I'll see you
pressed in the next video as always stay
awesome this flower let's give him a
flower in the pace Oh God
what are you doing that's that's the
whacking that's murder every